next question is from Morgan do you have
any political or other opinions that
have changed over time there are areas
where my views have changed pretty
significantly on politics a big one is
economics when I was in high school
junior year of high school I took ap
economics and it was totally standard
neoclassical capitalist economics with
no self critique of it
of itself I guess that's why it's a self
critique with no critique of what we
were being taught and I kind of started
to believe as the de facto obvious
reality that trickle-down economics
works that we have something close to a
an actual free-market system in our
economy and I believed for many years a
lot of what you would associate today
with Republicans when it comes to
economics and I thought a phrase that I
think now is insane
I'm socially liberal but fiscally
conservative I've since figured out that
that actually is in a way an oxymoron
I've also figured out that trickle-down
economics doesn't work and that
neoclassical economics is really really
important to learn and understand to
have sort of perspective conceptually
but that that's not actually how the
real world works and my views have
changed very significantly I mean if you
had talked to me when I was a freshman
and in over the summer between senior
and high school and freshman in college
you would have probably found me to be
pretty similar to somebody like a sort
of mainstream plutocratic Republican
senator on most economic issues I mean
my experience was pretty similar because
I grew up during the Bush administration
and you know that's one of the most
unpopular administration's of all time
so I was pretty liberal in response to
that very liberal on social issues when
I got to high school and Obama was in
charge I mean I had more libertarian
tendencies too I think part of that is
when you're younger you want to kind of
rebel against Authority you don't like
the the idea of some big government so I
think that's why libertarian appeal
libertarianism appeals to a lot of
people who are younger in that age group
that's true yeah
I think that again the sort of
caricature extreme literal
libertarianism is something that
hopefully once you realize why it makes
absolutely no sense
it's another ideology you start to move
away from as you actually learn stuff
the other aspect I think is and I've
talked about this a little bit before I
have been an advocate of gay rights for
as long as I can remember there was a
time where I think it was just a
combination of factors again I think my
freshman to sophomore time in college
where I I never thought that transgender
people should be discriminated against
or treated poorly or whatever but that I
sort of questioned the the legitimacy of
including the T in LGBT and I really
sort of saw it as this other thing that
we should really examine and think about
very differently of differently from LGB
and again I was never somebody who
thought anything negative about
transgender individuals as people but if
you had told me that the LGB fight is
the same thing as the LGBT fight in in
the ways in which it relates to laws
that should be past discrimination
ordinances etc I might have come off as
somehow indifferent to transgender
discrimination anti transgender
discrimination that's changed although
it's a far smaller change than with
economics I think that kind of makes
sense because the lesbian gay bisexual
part of that I think the goal at that
time was to achieve same-sex marriage
right and for transgenders I mean the
goal there wasn't nearly as clear it
certainly I don't know if you they would
be affected by by same-sex marriage as
much I guess it depends on a different
way I mean I would say yeah yes so I
guess it really depends on the issues
and I could see you trying to divide
those two things yeah and ultimately my
views have all done it and changed and
they sort of became with the Arnett they
are now those are the two really big
areas any other area you remember Pat
and it doesn't even have to be politics
just where your world view on something
changed drastically I mean after the
Affordable Care Act was passed I I
started looking into more conservative
critiques of the bill and it started to
become more against it hmm
I mean I I was it was very young at that
point I was you know
my early teenage years so I can see that
just seeing one side of the argument how
I would develop the opposing point that
I had all along yeah after you know kind
of opening my mind up to what we should
do with health care I think I've changed
quite significantly all right send me
your thoughts also completely unrelated
to politics my views have changed on
sort of the classics in literature when
I was younger I really just had a hard
time understanding the value and
importance of you know some of the
classics and 18th century Russian
literature etc and now I've really
enjoyed reading Dostoyevsky and so so
many other works of literature and maybe
that's just maturing I don't know it's
not really a change of opinion I guess
yeah you're expected to read these
classics in high school when maybe
you're not interested in the material
maybe your mind isn't at a point where
you can really understand it so I can
see you coming back 10 years later
wanting to read it